Welcome to watch me work.
Today we're using Teddy Builder gel
and adding a pop of colour with matcha latte.
My clients had this design before in brighter colours,
but never in a pastel,
so we thought we'd give that a go.
The design consists of three block colour nails,
one French tip
and one nail with swells.
So it's perfect for those of you who like a plain nail
but want something a little more playful.
My client mentioned
her cuticles had been feeling super dry lately,
so we made sure to lock that moisture back in
by absolutely drenching them in some enough stuff oil.
And this was our finished look.
This design adds just the right amount of cool girl
without looking too much.
What do you guys think?
Let me know in the comments.